citizens of the reject Nation this is my
non-spoiler across the spiderverse review
and I'm happy to say I think I have a new favorite
Spider-Man movie which means I have a new top 10
comic book movie and I think maybe even bigger
than that I've only ever given 22 films five
stars I think this is 23. across the spider verse
non-spoiler this is somehow a bigger leap in what
I think animation technology is than even the
first one I don't I don't know animation but
the things I saw are just mind-boggling
with the accomplishments and just visual
aesthetic notwithstanding the story is such an
accomplishment I felt so much for these characters
I love these characters already and I love them
even more now and it trusts the audience to have
a drama be told I think that the metamodernism of
Lord Miller is unique to itself they are somehow
always just ahead of the curve they are futurists
with comedy they're able to know what's about to
be funny and they really change the game with
comedy over and over again and I think that if
that Trend hopefully follows suit that's about
to happen with sincere drama this movie is so
sincere and honest and beautiful and heartfelt and
even in the the slow patient moments it it lets it
breathe and I think that's the beauty of this film
is that for example uh spider-gwen she's in the
trailers you know she's in the first movie she's
very much in this movie She's the co-lead of this
movie almost as much as miles in the screen time
and the artist who I think of with spider Gwen
is Jason latore Jason latore is this incredible
painted style and the film lets the Jason LaTour
art shape that whole world but the thing about the
Jason LaTour art is that it uh it kind of expands
and breathes horizontally and every time you're
in her world it it feels that expanding emotion
right and then like Miguel O'Hara Spider-Man 2099
he's from the future and rickly and already the
most iconic in my opinion most iconic Spider-Man
299 artist his art always feels like it's not
quite Complete because it's in the future and like
it's not quite finished in in a very conscious way
the future's not written yet Miguel's got these
beautiful accents around his face and he's got
these shapes that are like he's not quite there
and all of that's very intentional and it's all
a love letter to the art that reflects these
characters and that isn't just for nerds for
me but it's for the story it ties into the
story they're telling also the way they shape
the world I've talked about uh LaTour I've
talked about Leonardi but the actual worlds
themselves there's a lot of really interesting
things where this is gloriously spider-versal
and the way they shape even the worlds around the
characters also reflects the characters and it's
interesting because it's this nature nurture
thing right like you are your environment and
you know we can't really live in these worlds
for too long but what we can do is if you know
the character and you love the character that's
the environment so subconsciously your brain is
like Well yeah if it makes sense they'd be like
that but if you actually think about how people
are shaped and formed it's so cool to actually
see their environments and how the world they
came from informed them and that just builds the
character two-fold and I thought they handled all
of those broad ideas really well this masterfully
handles some very broad Concepts while delivering
much like the first film in quantum physics this
film delivers a lot of nature nurture where you
come from interesting things about belonging and
and what we are and man [__] Spider-Man movie
and then you've got like these amazing supporting
characters I mean obviously in the first one we
loved Spider-Man Noir and Peter Porker but in
this one there's there's so much interesting
storytelling that I do not want to give away
I'm very excited for the spoiler review but
the reason behind some things is tied directly
into these supporting characters and they are
hilarious you guys know Ben Reilly's in it and he
is one of my favorite characters and they don't
they know how to utilize him in a very unique
way and then they also have uh Spiderman India
and in a very unique setting and really really
tie the story beautifully to him and there's
still so many surprises this film has Far and
Away I think yeah it has my favorite Cameo this
film has my favorite Cameo of all time and
it's really unique to my sensibilities and
I don't want to give too much away in saying even
anything more than that but when I can talk about
it it's the Cameo I'm most excited to talk about
because it actually kind of looks at some of my
Cameo problems like it it solves some of my
issues with cameos and it's so ambitious and
so insane and it's it's really wonderful and and
once again when I can talk about it it beautifully
summarizes why I love this film so much and why I
love Lord and Miller's love for Spider-man and so
the movie itself is paced for adults it is a
drama it is at times very very introspective but
it's got so much levity and so much comedy
it's never heavy in a way that feels like a
hindrance it's heavy and it's thematic elements
it's heavy in some of it's storytelling but
it's like I said the metamodernism of drama
it's so self-aware in in its in its story
and it's drama but I hope that sincerity
is what we get out of this film because
it it's made for adults but kids could learn
so much from this story like how you wear the
mask is so important and and what you do in these
moments is so important and I think the first film
really was a cultural shift and I think this
one has that same potential and to be honest
they're so such a bigger story like I love stories
about family and I love stories that involve power
and responsibility that's why Spider-Man's my guy
but so often they feel like they've been told they
so often feel like uh you know you're coloring
by numbers and this one I I was surprised at
so many twists and turns I mean not just the
the obvious stuff like you know your Easter
eggs and your cameos in those moments but genuine
storytelling turns surprised me because it's it's
it's such a beautiful new story to tell and by the
time you're at the end I didn't want this movie to
end and it's over two hours and I just wanted to
live in this world I wanted to experience this
world and the chemistry these actors and shamik
Moore is even more Miles Morales he's even more
uh just the the this this man this this young man
who's coming into his own and Haley steinfeld's
chemistry with shamique is incredible and this
is maybe my favorite take ever on spider Gwen
like I love spider Gwen in the comics and a
huge fan of spider-gwen but there's something
about the way she plays her that it takes all the
elements of Gwen that I like and makes me love
them and it adds more there's this beautiful hard
innocence there's this beautiful freedom but you
you understand why some of the choices you're like
disagreeing with she would make and it's really
well done and once again miles's father steals
every scene for me I love Brian Tyree Henry brings
to this character I love Jeffrey the mom here gets
a lot more time to play uh Mrs Morales and she is
so the heart of this film I I cannot wait to give
spoilers on this but it is very much the sequel I
needed it to be but it's more different than I
expected I'm glad the marketing didn't give too
much away I'm glad the movie itself trusted me and
I think most of all I'm glad that Spider-Man being
so Universal so multifaceted allowed the movie
to keep surprising me even as a Spider-Man fan
because there's things that happen in the comic
books that happen in the film but then they like
play with those so their story elements you'll
recognize but then they add layers onto it and
and to be honest this is bordering on spoiler
but this is everything I wanted Multiverse of
Madness to be this is everything I want this new
sub-genre of multiversal impact to be it lands all
of the swings the other movies have tried this is
the everything everywhere all at once Spider-Man
and I'm in love with it it is so very good it
is so very special it's Spider-Man and uh yeah I
think this is my new favorite Spider-Man movie and
that's saying a lot Easter eggs cameos all of the
things you could want in that uh you know more
modern uh people look for it in their in their
clip out videos but in the more traditional sense
of Storytelling it is every bit the drama every
bit The Love Letter to love and family every bit
the laugh a minute cry a minute later comedy drama
just just love letter to Spider-Man that I wanted
it to be I'm uh I'm happy to report five stars
a plus across the spider versus everything Lord
Miller he did it again thank you thank you thank
you for taking such good care of these characters
I love so much I cannot wait to see it again leave
a comment below let me know which character you're
most excited to see let me know who you're most
excited to see debut or who you're most excited
to see return let me know in the comments below
once you've seen it who your favorite character
was which World which artist I just this movie
foreign